[Musique]
il ya des grands voyages qu'on oublie
toujours de faire des pays aussi
fantastique que les îles lofoten nous
l'aimons tumu cumac oui je crois qu'il
ya encore des planètes oublier des
endroits bizarres seulement voilà à
force de les voir on ne les regarde plus
[Musique]
effectivement on peut vous poser une ou
deux questions fait un film sur le métro
et quelle impression cette question tout
ça parce que vous prenez le métro
souvent n'ait pas marché
et combien de temps vous y passer chaque
jour
[Musique]
aux deux amis
des heurts
une vingtaine de minutes le matin même
c'est par exemple de gare du nord je
vais la garder lyon je change à pastique
alors ça me fera dix ans que 25 minutes
quoi j'évitais je vis il n'y a pas d'air
c'est pas parce que vous avez peur
jamais faire
j'ai brutalement non
il y en a que ça de près oui vous avez
rappeur dans deux agressions sont assez
fréquentes
j'ai mes gars gré cm
tu penses pas je me promène pas déjà
les stations où j'ai peur
ils ont guère faire de davié par exemple
il est évident qu'à partir de stalingrad
c'est tellement sûr passer certaines
heures quoi excusez moi madame une
seconde on fait un film sur la
télévision pour métro
une question
[Musique]
moi je suis parisien
je crois moi je regardais pas mme d
je m'occupe
comme ça je regarde à gauche angélil a
pas perdu tant pis si non je regarde
autour de moi
les gens sont durs la tente
pourquoi je suis pas tout le monde est
triste
[Musique]
m
quatre millions d'habitants trois cent
trente stations 240 kilomètres de
couloirs depuis 82 ans le métro c'est
bien plus qu'un moyen de transport
en fait c'est un pays où on n'arrive
jamais un continent aussi exotique avec
une salsa de jamaïque que chacun d'entre
nous tous les jours traverse les yeux
fermés
[Musique]
chacun salue me chacun sa station où son
couloir chacun son itinéraire mur par
jour ça fait pourtant quinze jours par
an est un parisien prend sa retraite
demande lui un peu de faire le compte
il aura passé plus d'une année entière
dans ce labyrinthe sans jamais s'y
arrêter m
[Musique]
il ya peu d'endroits au monde pourtant
ce mélange autant de classes sociales
drass où s'additionnent autant de petits
drames de solitude de plaisir cacher
en inaugurant leur métropolitain le 19
juillet 1900 les français je crois non
pas réalisé qu'il venait de s'inventer
est en fait une deuxième capitale
[Musique]
et depuis dix ans tout a changé dans
cette métropole fantôme plus de
poinçonneur des lilas recul chef de
station à casquette
ici comme partout ailleurs les machines
ont remplacé les hommes
alors le métro est devenu un lieu plus
un anime plus du mur
plus effrayant aujourd'hui les parisiens
ont peur très peur de ce métro dante
hier encore il parlait avec beaucoup de
tendresse
ça suit celle de la ligne 13 châtillon
montrouge années j'avais eu depuis
quelques mois seulement avant j'étais
chef de la ligne 12 1 de mérici attend
de la chapelle depuis quatre ans non
j'ai exercé le chef de ligne depuis
quatre ans je fais partie maintenant ce
qu'on appelle les anciens et j'ai
commencé mon métier tout à fait à la
base parce que là j'ai commencé comme
moissonneurs chef de train conducteur
agents de maîtrise et ensuite
l'inspecteur j'ai vécu cette période de
mutation entre le métro ancien système
qu'on appelle couramment métro de papa
et le métro actuel et c'est vrai que
nous avons subies le terme n'est pas
trop fort à nous subissons un peu de
tout cette automatisation qui a été il
n'a pas été sans blessé quand même
quelques séquelles au niveau du
personnel
[Musique]
visuellement on annonce 6 % de toute
fraude
et ce taux de fraude est quand même une
incidence relativement importante
puisque si on pouvait diminuer ce taux
de fraude de moitié c'est-à-dire les
faire diminuer de 3%
on pourrait financer quand le salaire et
les charges sociales de 400 agents ce
qui justifie le l'orientation actuelle
on va remettre des agents sur le quai et
devant les lignes de contrôle
[Musique]
sk des lignes qui sont plus difficiles
que d'autres
difficile le
or être un petit peu sollicitant parce
que
on nous a beaucoup dit par exemple que
la ville 4t beaucoup plus difficile que
les autres pourquoi ça se tient
certaines catégories clientèle des
clients tels qu'ils sont
vous avez dit qu'ils sont
traditionnellement
clientèle d'habitation a d'autres qui
sont habitués à caractère commercial de
limoux naissante avec des magasins vous
avez aussi celles qui sont
[Musique]
et je
avec certains quartiers dmp les
étudiants
et puis certains lieux de loisirs qui
amène quelques voix une faune qui est
assez difficile comme clientèle qui
pourront pas mal de problèmes
le personnel que ce soit des clochards
où même des marginaux de toutes sortes
1 nous subissons le fait que nous sommes
à refuge en refuge et du fait de la
déshumanisation des quais du métro ben
ça remue un refuge naturel puisque
n'importe qui peut y rester
ii y stationner alors que par le passé
par la présence des agents
1 ces gens là on les faisait circuler il
ne restait pas dans notre univers
et
et là
et très doux
laissez tomber
et des fois mes frères et soeurs
[Musique]
j'avais ça va les gagnants ont jusque là
tél
dans ce refuge là on compte maintenant
toutes sortes d'habitants je veux dire
de vrais habitants les gens qui vivent
là du matin au soir
certains sont là depuis des années de
nombreuses années en vérité ce sont des
personnages de prévert
[Musique]
madame ça fait longtemps vous fait sa
thèse en trente ans que je le fais
actuellement mais pas toujours à la même
place
[Musique]
oui
tout
trois ans que je suis un chalet du reste
vous pouvez regarder en dessous mais
jusqu'où commun au machin là ma béquille
j'ai le trou de l'empattement de ma
béquille est en dessous du genou j'ai la
marque de mai et depuis 23 ans d'où
venaient là tous les jours certaines
heures de 7 heures du matin jusqu'à 9h15
du matin pour vienne le chercher et
comment alors qu'elle il ya quelqu'un
qui vous amène qui vient chercher un
petit pompier qui qui travaille à la
samaritaine
donner à peu près dans les 50 à 60
francs par jour s'imposait à 2 quad ou
un centre anglais que maintenant entre
20 et 25 cents par jour c'est le maximum
je ne viens que le à partir du lundi 8
jusqu'au vendredi matin parce ie9 samedi
il y a personne
le dimanche encore bien entre mendiants
on a deux estime sûr sûr sûr certains
comprenait pas ce que j'en aie qui
méritent pas qu'on leur donne palestine
partout
c'était que ceux qui ne respectent pas
ou ceux ceux qui veulent vivre que dans
la crasse du montant de la mince c'est
pour un litre de rouge
on voit que d'autres ils tendent la main
c'est pour pouvoir se payer un petit
bien être c'est à dire se payer une
chambre puis de rester propre
il faut être très diplomate avec les
gens et puis c'est beaucoup de la
psychologie
[Musique]
paris may me dit tu sais pas pendant
trois semaines
j'étais un petit peu malade là lorsqu'on
tient peu plus tôt
m
[Musique]
c'est pas bien ce puits
pas
[Musique]
ap
[Applaudissements]
c'était un samedi soir à l'heure du
cinéma on a transporté d'urgence à
l'hôpital le plus proche le cracheur de
feu de la station pigalle il était
gravement brûlé
[Musique]
on espère parce que leur histoire
something
allez on a le sourire déjà je peux dire
certains légumes
ça fait rien ce soir je vous laisse pas
ce que jésus occupée
sinopoli vous aurez paye c'est pas aussi
facilement
tous les clochards du temps sont
philosophes bernard pourtant n'est pas
un clochard tout à fait ordinaire en mai
68 casqués bottés
il était crs
or les gens de leur ordinaire dire
qu'ils sortent ils sortent de leur métro
de prendre prochain
tu éclaires de couture réveil du réveil
de rodières pur dignité pourquoi
pièce même sur la salle et réveille et
de plutôt regarder tourner en tant
qu'être humain et en tant qu'être humain
ce moment-là devait y avoir un échange
si à des gens qui n'ont rien trouvé
quand même une fois qu'il demanderait de
bord doivent êtres humains qui gâtent
pour mettre en condition pour sentir le
guillou il faut aussi social clients
sentir le client
oui parce que si tu arrives donnant
droit au faux pas comme s'est demandé
pourquoi
il sent le futur itif côté plus de
cigarettes
je reconnais les clients non tu
reconnais pas tendance à me vue qui
passent des gens si j'en aï n'en
revenant pas cinq minutes après mais tu
auras santé de climat du couloir de
métro
là tu demanderas dans l'ambiance je vois
quelqu'un courir
monsieur petite pièce n'a pas le temps
de me donner une petite pièce et alors
'pour l'instant même pour dire non dire
non peut-être
il aura mis un temps a repéré qu'il y
avait quelqu'un d'humain en face de lui
donc tu donnes dans la vie je reçois
obligatoirement
et si tu reçois donc dû tu te sens
coupable
djamila
vous faites ça pendant la nuit
et ça vous plaît c'est normal si on a
une grande liberté dans le crâne
relativement impressionnant on fait
toujours la une station châtelet hôtel
de ville depuis combien de temps ça va
faire un an et ça fait combien affiche
par ansa moi je peux pas en vous disant
jean représente quand même par an
je peux pas vous dire le chiffre exact a
enfin comme un gros millier de passe
les gens me connaissent on en connaît on
connaît dès janvier
sont-ils les intéressent à ce que vous
collez je pense comme
[Musique]
mais depuis quelques années le métro à
ces nouveaux marginaux c'est un signe
des temps
jeunes chômeurs baba cool peau mais ils
ont déjà leurs habitudes leurs lieux de
rencontre près du grand tapis le grand
tapis roulant de montparnasse par
exemple
je pense que vous faites dans le
moi j'attends quelqu'un à j'attends des
gens que je connais et puis
conseils de mon dû
de trouver du travail vous êtes au
chômage plus ou moins dix ans je
travaille
c'est un bâton riz en même temps je
dans le métro souvent comme ça on
rencontre des gens
mi temps passe et je perds et pour une
heure de
trois heures mais fois toute une matinée
mais pourquoi le métro plutôt qu'autre
chose
dix ans que mon
les amis que je ferai quand ils sont
souvent en mai
wilson s'est plus ou moins
du travail
ce rendez vous c'est le point de
rendez-vous toute façon les bétons
surtout à montparnasse
vous êtes toujours à montparnasse où
j'aimerais mon carnet c'est pourquoi mon
barda et aux meilleurs
ce qu on se trouve bien
montcornet sans égal
en 1982 si l'on en croit la direction de
la ratp cinq ou six cents jeunes
chômeurs ou loubards livre ainsi en
permanence dans les couloirs
bon je vais souvent dans le métro ah oui
beaucoup tous les jours 2
8h30 il en 11 heures et demie jusqu'à
août dernier soir entre copains copines
et pourquoi vous êtes dans le métro où
des messages oui puis après midi je sais
pas quoi cote années que je travaille le
soir
la boîte de nuit
explosif
ce que choquer
dans les vestiaires c'est un compact
grand place
comment l'après midi j'ai peint depuis
nice
toujours à montparnasse c'est toujours à
montparnasse j'aime beaucoup
montparnasse a beaucoup
mais le métro c'est pas marrant d'être
tout le temps dans le métro 8e mondial
mais j'aimerais pourquoi ça expliquez
moi c'est pas compris
j'ai pas j'aime bien il ya du monde
beaucoup de contacts
indifférents les tulipes cas violer son
avenir a dit françois mancel à 10 ans
pas d'euphorie sida
j'en ai philippe moati forme
c'est pas cher
[Musique]
agissements de violette rétablissement
fleury pas cher
le métro c'est aussi tiers-monde tous
les pays de la terre sont là
à bien regarder toutes les tragédies
internationale sans exception aboutisse
un jour ou l'autre sur le quai d'une
station ou au pied d'un escalator de la
ratp
vous venez de quel pays les cyclos dix
ans
du cambodge et
ap
vous êtes en france depuis combien de
temps
mais depuis cinq ans vous vendez des
bijoux dans le métro
aussi le filet come on
il fait la guerre
dans mon pays
usine oui
elle se soit la bicyclette
est ce que vous arrivez à faire vivre
votre famille en vendant des bijoux dans
le métro il ya suffisamment de clients
ça marche
certainement
[Musique]
un enfant
le faire ce soir
deux filles et des garçons
[Musique]
deux filles là bas il n'y a pas le feu
je vis de mal mais ma femme
hamon
aussi trois mais rester là bas oui mais
voilà pas le web aucune nouvelle d'elle
[Musique]
c'est pas m
c'est ça
[Musique]
dans le métro comme en afrique les chefs
reste des chefs
les deux balayeurs et leur chef que nous
avons rencontrés au métro châtelet un
après-midi viennent du grand fleuve
sénégal
ils ont quitté gaulle ni un village
écrasée de chaleur à la limite du désert
de mauritanie a goal me et dans toute la
région vivent les sonic et grands
commerçants africains et propriétaires
fonciers et dans ces villages soninké la
balle et bambara une autre ethnie venus
du mali forme un sous prolétariat de
travailleurs saisonniers au métro
châtelet ce jour là les deux bandar a
balayé les couloirs sous les ordres du
contremaître soninké ici comme là-bas
[Musique]
et sous payés exploiter les balayeurs
métro qu'il soit sonic m bambara
sénégalais ou maliens sont nos sous
prolétaires à nous
[Musique]
à plusieurs reprises en 79 en 1980 ils
se sont mit spectaculairement en grève
ils réclamaient notamment le droit
d'utiliser les mêmes vestiaires et les
mêmes toilettes que les agents de la
ratp
on est toujours le bambara de quelqu'un
[Musique]
s
il ya trois mois par être humain ce
n'est pas la volonté du département
and you do you know in nous n'ont pas
tous les problèmes
quel romancier howett imaginez la scène
dans un couloir de la station pigalle un
bengali vendeurs de mimosa rencontre un
et pas les débarquer de katmandou en
cinq minutes il se découvre un langage
commun et engage une longue conversation
dans un des dialectes des contreforts de
l'himalaya
n'importe qui vous achetez des plages
vais chez ma cousine tout simplement je
veux lui faire un petit cadeau ça
m'arrive assez souvent parce que ces
pratiques alors plutôt que de m'arrêter
chez un fleuriste oui faut du temps
je prends différentes missions du
bangladesh c'est ça fait trois mois
qu'il est en france depuis
marc burg en cercle
la bière est chassé
[Musique]
de même respecter la ligne numéro de vie
numéro 10 enfants vers les sommets
mythiques et notamment je viens de dire
les jambes
après il y aurait 20 européens auraient
dû conduire un imperméable crem a les
cheveux plaqués commis des gens armés
d'un pistolet
elle emploie majoré armée de
rembarré vieux produits entre
en mer et odéon ya une demande
[Musique]
pour
tu fais ça souvent la manche dans le
métro voilà j en allemand tous les jours
tous les jours et longtemps au revoir
si longtemps non mais tu fais deux
longtemps chaque jour 3 une ou deux
heures et les gens les genres de nos
échecs près des points de différence de
francs une fois perdu tout sens général
plus à rien que les gens souffrent et
meurent sous le coup tu fais à manger tu
arrives à ramasser combien d'argent
à ses dépens un jour j'ai fait encore 24
heures dit sac à mon record non c'est
pas ça
rien c'est serré j'étais à austerlitz tu
fais la manche et joue un mec super bien
ça pis regarde les champs bon je revis
on va raser j ai abandonné pendant la
gueule ça arrive des fois jazz de
montreux
je prends à trouillas j'étais répond un
franc il vous regarde sur eux ils sont
partout donne le portefeuille d'un
cercle gymnique comme moi elle valait
volet sport est malade c'est vraiment
audi a6 renom pourquoi tu as choisi ça
parce qu'elle va voir je ne pouvais pas
comme ça gérer la mèche en 18 juin des
fraudeurs ingénierie est jeune on
m'appelle m'appelle johnny maintenant je
me suis à la base nous plier à johnny
hallyday
j'adore j'adhère préféré mon enfance
j'aime aussi beaucoup à coeur j'aimerais
sort les crocs kral gérer tout ça kresic
ravanne celui à 30 ans à albas de clips
en mai contre 1 tué marie moreau et je
te promet elle aussi je le super fan
c'est bon là tu viens d'où
france 2 paris de chez argenta rythme
mais je suis je suis l'assistance
publique
enfin le taxage ses vaches r qu'est ce
que c'est le taxage sa mettons un terme
au blouson il va bluffer mackillop
apparemment je prend d'un coup tu le
donnes
au port ou non rasoir mais qui gère
classe a déjà là bas j'ai fait une ou
deux fois dans l'obligation de ne plus
rien j'ai pu le menacer avec quoi quand
il attaque c'est une golden plein de
couteaux
non jamais parce que moi je suis souvent
contrôlés par les choeurs alors c'est la
langue arabe tient compte aussi sur un
cran d'arrêt la banque est devant vous
non bloqués
vider mes poches et m'ont fouillé
mais en garde à vue pour chercher tu
serais trop dans la gare
mes potes qui étaient aussi je t'ai eue
c'est en réalité je vous le bouton du à
comment t'as fait ça et on m'appelle le
roi de la cameroun heureusement l on
peut trouver parce que comme je repris
de justice jugée par la justice
je suis tombé grande a réouvert était en
2h06 les plus hauts j'avais clippers
écoute entendent bien sympa à dijon
serait pas mal on le voit beaucoup et on
gagne les clochards présent bien passer
pour le mec est beau mais bon on l'a
enlevé comme ça nous c'est différent des
zonards parce qu'on est jeune nous
derrière toujours pour être propre monde
et douches à la gamme cellex c les
fringues qui inclura des magouilles l'un
des pions et des combines et par moments
de peur de devenir pêcheur 30 ha sera
vieux quand je serai vieux si si si on y
pense richard alors de vie qu'est ce que
vous pensez de l'aggravation de
l'insécurité dans le métro en france je
pense pas beaucoup de bien
le
le problème si vous voulez c'est qu'on a
affaire donc
une toute petite petite délinquance qui
tend effectivement à se multiplier ça on
ne peut pas le
l'aimiez mai mais on al'impression
excusé mort d'un être sans que les gens
depuis les parisiens ont de plus en plus
peur de remettront est ce que c est ce
qu ils sont fondés avoir peur bon c'est
vrai que la petite délinquance cette
petite délinquance augmente
donc peut dans une certaine meunier
mesure dire que les parisiens sont
fondées effectivement avoir à avoir peur
maintenant je bois comme assistée / sur
une chose bien particulière il ya tout
un imaginaire du métro et al
c'est à lui de vase clos c'est un lieu
d'enfermement se taper une descente aux
enfers déjà pourtant quand on prend le
métro
et puis tout simplement je vais vous
donner quelques chiffres en 1981
grosso modo la police judiciaire a
relevé environ 800 agression peu près
pour l'année 10 et ce en 1981 alors
quand je parle l'agression c'est vole
avec violence et coups et blessures
volontaires ce qui représente vont à peu
près de deux agressions et demie par
jour pour quatre millions et demi de
personnes transportées quotidiennement
dans le métro
[Musique]
par ailleurs il faut reconnaître que
lorsque la presse parle du métro c'est
c'est le flagrant délit de vol à la tire
c'est l'agression à coups de couteaux
enfin c'est le fait divers et c'est ce
que les gens retiennent en définitive
[Musique]
je vais été agressé dans le métro mais
c'était à peu près une semaine un soir à
8h30
je prenais métro direction porte
d'orléans et en face il y avait peu près
une quarantaine d'africains qui
dansaient qui écoutait du reggae et de
ce côté là donc où j'étais il y en avait
trois ou quatre et moi je suis allé
spontanément m'asseoir à côté d'eux
puisque pour écouter la musique et des
queues
je me suis assis on est venu vers moi
qui me disent que tu as de l'argent je
dis oui merci aux jeunes d'argent et
charles faye qui les y pelé santé mais
didot ne voulut duel pourquoi pas preuve
du pad en plus je te donne tout mais il
y avait des pêcheurs alors j'ai vu il
plaisanté pas j'ai dit non pas question
je veux partir
il était violent n'était pas violent
mais enfin quand même ils étaient disons
assez autoritaire
ils ont dit aux sa santé était bloquée
notre entre copains en face et nous on
est trois ans qu'ils soient pas partir
et puis à ce moment allait l'appeler ses
amis comme ont immobilisé sur le bord
l'a maintenu les mains les pieds et
l'autre noté à l'époque chuté dans le
sait qu'en face il ya métro qui arrivait
et tous les gens regarder ça ils ont
raison des princes était une scène de
film aux quelque chose et moi
bon ça pas été dramatique en soi mais
c'est extrêmement humiliant d'un
vraiment l'impression d'être le pigeon
de la farce
et après ils m'ont expliqué vont une
fois que mes fait les poches
évitez absolument tous m'ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'argent pour vivre avec
lui taxer les gens comme ça les rastas
qu'est ce que c'est
alors ah ça c'est cool qui sont
tranquilles qui fument gains tout qui
coûte la musique est belle et papineau
ne peut pas tu vas vis et babylone il va
bien si des flics mais lens a déjeuné
avec deux fois qu'est ce qui se passe
abbas à [ __ ] la merde tout ça ils sont
pas d'accord entre eux quoi
il ya combien de temps que tu es souvent
dans le métro comme ça qu'est ce que tu
fais comme boulot moi comme j'ai dit je
fais j'ai des gens qui sont tous dans la
merde tu vois qu'ils sont en danger
on y sept ont tous en bon dans les bacs
boys on donne un coup de main en vérité
je veux dire comment tu gagnes ta vie
moi
[Musique]
non non
travaillant dans le métro
[Musique]
qui va
d'accord
et
ja
dans le métro n'ont fait part il ya
quelques mois nous donnera charité kfor
avait confié comme ça avec nos papilles
et également expliqué moi je dis non moi
je mets comme ça jean marc et georges
tron et jo mais oui je m'en vais comme
ça comme ça burgos nord non et moi je
vole pas beaucoup moins quatre fois je
repense on n'a pas d'argent pour manger
mal on n'a pas marché nous tous
contraints à la dizaine des
petits-enfants dizaines et parce que
nous nous n'a pas personnes qui
travaillent chez nous versons personne
qui travaille travaille pas on n'avait
pas assez à la mamelle n'aurait pas
quand mon père est mort tout seul tu as
quel âge péter l'âge
oui tout ça nous disons que là je sais
c'est un 8 6 1 et moi c'est vraiment ça
rosa et ya laquelle celle à 10 heures
vitaa noms qui font bien marrer à
navailles trouvera à la police qu'elle
vous embête nos édiles avril vous arrête
pas la police dit qu'il faut arrêter en
chemin jusqu'à mon resto matin au matin
on attrape
nous resterons jusqu'à 6 au 17 octobre
comme ça nous reste à la louis nord
espagne et tout ça parce qu'on nous aide
des mineurs pourquoi nous fait rien et
l'argent qui devenait bon nombre mais
pas là à mes parents mes parent sais pas
qui moi jaune et chapeau nom safrané
nous était policier
voilà core 2 quad core i7 ou qui supplée
la police elle est là la police est là
haut peut-être ne m'a marqué nous allons
amener à paris on sait pas y en a
maintenant on ne sait pas mais rien
la police a 20 ans et demi nous on va
rester avec nous et après à toi toi pour
les faits sont là qu'à policiers sont
morts à 10 ans
et maintenant
[Musique]
face à elle pas une télé spectateurs qui
voient ça qui doit se dire vraiment que
fait la police
domaine il faut savoir que ces mineurs
effectivement qui ont entre 6 et 13 ans
à peu près son bon représente à peu près
10% de la population des voleurs à la
tire et représente 40 % volume des vols
à la tire ce qui est quand même ce qui
vous donne une proportion ils sont
vraiment très efficace et aucun problème
à dire qu'ils font pour eux seuls près
de la moitié des vols en quantité
révolte est à peu près 40% c'est un
septième c'est un minimum alors le
problème pour nous il est surtout de les
rouler de les déférer efficacement
j'allais dire la justice parce que vous
savez que avant 13 ans miller ne peut
pas être saisi pénalement par là on ne
peut pas être accessible à une sanction
pénale
donc il n'est pas question de mettre mis
en garde à vue pour nous il n'est pas
question de le mettre en prison ou bien
à fortiori après et ce sont des gens que
nous interpellons parfois trois fois
dans la même journée voire donc 28 fois
dans le même mois j'ai fait faire des
statistiques a pas très longtemps et qui
ressortent au maximum deux heures trois
heures après
du commissariat parce qu'il n'existe
aucune aucune institution
susceptibles de les actes
[Musique]
il
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans le métro d'avant-hier quelques
accords de nice est aveugle ou
violoniste un certain occuper les
carrefours stratégiques
c'était des silhouettes familières et
puis au fil des années et sans qu'on
s'en rende vraiment compte une petite
révolution s'est produite la musica en
veille métro tout entier c'est peut être
la contrepartie de l'inquiétude
une revanche sur la grisaille chaque
jour un peu partout dans les couloirs se
donne ainsi des tas de petites fêtes
éparpiller les voyageurs pressés les
parisiens cafardeuse trouve le temps
matin ou soir d'arrêter la bousculade
pour en partager quelques notes et si
c'était ça la vraie musique
[Musique]
le voir
à
on
oh
[Musique]
on
ok
[Musique]
hahaha
s'emballe monsieur lama sans mal
monsieur
sandra monsieur
[Musique]
e
santé
[Musique]
à
il ya longtemps que tu fais ce métier
bats depuis que je connais moi-même oui
c'est à dire non mais je veux dire dans
le métro dans le métro bas
depuis que je suis à paris ça fait cinq
ans
pourquoi tu as choisi le métro plutôt
qu'autre chose bah dans le métro moi
j'ai choisi le métro parce que ça me
fait travailler la voix
voyez ça fait
la reverb naturel il n'y a pas besoin
d'acheter une fin du matériel pour
travailler sa voix
et puis
[Musique]
ça me fait
un contact sacré en contact avec les
gens on est tout de suite confrontées
avec le public
et puis ronde publique étant donné que
je compose mes propres d'être maintenant
que
par la suite je compte enfin ces
pourparlers avec bart est aussi
maintenant donc
mes titres eux
en au public si vous voulez peut me
rassurer ou alors il peut me dire comme
quoi je fais la merde je fais une
journée en faisant ça
je vais vous dire franchement je viens
pas seulement pour le fric je viens pour
travailler mon droit vivre quand vous
regardez mes chansons avant que je les
enregistre
bon moi je gagne 3 4 centre pour
quatre à cinq heures de travail
vitry ouest
l'hostie cela représente beaucoup
d'argent par jour mais je sens bien je
moyenne
cinq premiers france vs pariot 3110 gaz
par jour qui viennent du métro oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
j'ai fait le conservatoire des
saxophones des sarabandes région de
versailles
vega s'est fait jour
orgasme
après si la fuite avec
merveilleux d appeler aux jacobins qui
malheureusement nous a quittés il ya
quelques années et je n'ai pas de
travail
[Musique]
et
oh
formidable je retrouve le contact avec
le public des échanges on peut jouer
toutes sortes de musique disons que nous
on fait plutôt mieux classés qu'eux
regardez une certaine rigueur nous a dit
le classique marché très bien en
j'avais un retour du classique oui oui
dans le métro mais je ne sais pas disons
que l'ensemble d'un ensemble qui
s'appelle dans ce hangar propos ni les
contrats
officiel ça
sont donc on vient se faire connaître
dans le métro ils ont joué on fait de la
musique on existe toujours et comme me
disait un ami
dernièrement il m'a dit si la musique
est maintenant dans le métro à londres
le métro ni pourquoi pas on y regarde
par jour en jour dans métro
je ne sais pas bien je vais vous
répondre
le segment on peut gagner beaucoup mais
c'est très fatigant vrai j'aurais vite
vos plongées c'est à dire
[Musique]
pour musiciens du métro on peut gagner
500 francs par jour même plus
mais c'est quand même fatigue ans et tu
as trahi ans et moins personnellement je
ne veux pas je mette une limite pour ne
pas qu'on ne va pas le métro et une
salle de concert qui est ouverte de 7
heures du matin à minuit
bon on pourrait travailler
quinze heures par jour ça je veux pas le
faire un stakhanoviste du médecin
bon on va le faire je crois qu'il faut
le faire rethel peut-être même dans le
style concert je donnais son répertoire
pendant un certain temps et puis
[Musique]
des hommes et des femmes que personne ne
remarque font quelquefois s'asseoir dans
le métro pour rien pour un moment de
chaleur anonyme
ils suivent des yeux les couples trop
occupés d'être deux ici plus intensément
qu'à la surface des solitudes se
croisent et se cherche des regards se
font signe on a beaucoup écrit sur la
solitude des grandes villes beaucoup
moins sur celle du métro ce n'est pas
tout à fait la même
[Musique]
mais le fait d'être tout seul comme ça
pendant des heures dans un tunnel à quoi
vous pensez vous être c
non moi ça me gêne pas trop parce que je
chez bricoleur moi alors je pense à
l'état de choses fait de la mécanique
pour moi je fais plein de choses vous
voyez je fais de la photo par exemple je
vais faire cette photo là je faire si je
veux faire ça je regarde y'a des moments
ça me paraît bien le moment l'appareil
photo sucre
bon ben ça voilà je pense à plein temps
pensez tourne trop jeune on pense trop
métro sont là ils sont seuls ils
s'ennuient dans des gros problèmes il ya
beaucoup de gens ayant des dépressions
nerveuses
[Musique]
et longtemps vous attendez
vous attendez qu'ils ont deux filles que
et comment si vous la connaissez pas
comment voulez juste entrevu dans le
métro il ya à peu près un mois
ah bon et puis
et puis j'essaie de la revoir parce que
parce qu elle était mignonne et kleber
gentille version de reconnaître de
reconnaître oui comment elle et les
bruits
relativement grand nez
[Musique]
sous la rubrique chéri le journal
libération publie deux fois par semaine
des annonces un peu particulière le
métro y occupe une place importante
une fois sur trois au moins c'est là
qu'on se donne anonymement rendez vous
ce samedi après midi à saint placide une
lesbienne de 20 ans cherchait une
partenaire signe de reconnaissance un
paquet de dany la libération à la main
cinq jeunes femmes étaient déjà au
rendez vous
est ce que vous avez donné rendez-vous
dans le métro qu'ailleurs dans l'autre
parce que si c'est le premier lieu
auquel on pense souvent n'a pas
d'adressé ou donner un signe à une
adresse ou un café qui vous viennent un
leader on est trop hazard frau hazard on
va trop loin de chez vous ils avouent
penser que quelqu'un va venir
on espère vous avez repéré deux à des
jeunes femmes qui sont du pur simple
d'apparence jack points mais j'en suis
pas sûr
alors comment ça va se passer vont venir
vous dire bonjour j'espère parce que je
suis un peu timide êtes timide un peu au
début et si elles vous plaisent pas
qu'est ce que vous voudrez offs et le
verbe clair je n'aime pas tellement ce
parce que je pense que si le physique
ses pattes le plus important elle vaut
mieux connaître les gens moralement qui
ne va pas on peut trouver un petit
charme
ouais aux parents ils le savent par
exemple
ah oui oui son parfum depuis deux ans
depuis deux ans mais ils sont riches aux
habitudes jeunes puis ça normal bailat
feu et il a fallu mener un grand combat
pendant un an et demi que mon gars de
leur expliquer ils ont compris comment
vous avez décidé lundi un jour je crois
que j'ai passé
avec des pincettes il y aura dit
carrément papa et moi je suis lesbienne
ou me fait suer avec les mecs c'est vrai
c'est quelque chose en jarez
moi ce que vous reconnaissez les gens
qui viennent pour autre chose que ce
qu'on fait habituellement dans les
toilettes niveau toujours dans le coin
des urinoirs
alors j'ai surveille et puis je vois
quatre jambes en basse couche on va plus
que deux alors je me mets là je leur
demande s'ils veulent que je les aide
alors elles sont honteux et 100 go et un
petit pépère qui vient souvent là puis
j'ai repéré aussi c'est vrai mais qu'est
ce qu'il fait bah je sais pas il regarde
c'est parce qu'il fait de regarder
comment surmonter au sérieux il rien
c'est tout oui enfin si challenger et
noir joueront pas ce qu'ils font c'est
quand même pas les regarder de près
alors je me mets là puis j'ai repris
après eux ils s'en vont ça vous choque
non non non la vie d'autres merci
donc vous surveillance en relation des
dans les cabines s'il devait y avoir des
chalets pas encore eu de demande la
passe qui demanda aux principales
entrées hdmi encore normalement il
demande à rentrer deux et vous et vous
leur autoriser mois s'était encore
jamais arrivé alors je sais pas mais
quelle est la règle dans ce cas là un
ballon faut refuser on n'a pas le droit
non pas le droit et maintenant voilà on
nous demande d'aller dans les cabines
avec eux sapho reçu ces moments de
bonheur et kévin a vécu des malades quoi
il monte dans les cinq minutes avec eux
dans les cabines contre de l'argent
quand on a de l'argent on vous a déjà
demandé ça ici il ya une quinzaine de
jours et quand vous avez refusé
qu'est-ce qui le dit on me dit faut pas
refuser les hôtes artus pas ben je leur
ai dit d'aller voir les autres moi ça
m'intéresse pas
[Musique]
120 secondes
croyez moi ça
[Musique]
et pour
pourquoi vous plairait
est ce qu'on peut
[Musique]
pourquoi vous pleurez d'argent
c'est parce que c'est des gens qui vont
au marché qu'ils n'ont pas le temps non
il ya longtemps de la non
[Musique]
je
mais j'ai pas compris racontez moi votre
soeur vous travaillez vous travaillez
pas
deux coiffeuses pas de travail parce
qu'elle n'a pas un
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours la manche dans le métro
elle a cole c'est pas bon ça
vu que quand je fais ça je peux faire la
manche et pourquoi
que ces montants bois
fait quand vous faites la manche va
pouvoir du courage
[Musique]
c'est mauvais
il ya longtemps que vous faites ça
[Musique]
je veux dire des suicides
dans ces cas là qu'est ce que vous
pouvez avoir il faut s'arrêter enfin
nage d'urgence
elle est immédiatement coupé le courant
demandé la coupure du courant
actionnement d'une barrette de rector
d'alarmé barrette rouge
mais vous n'avez aucune chance d'arrêter
le train avant ben ça dépend où se jette
la personne
oui mon premier suicide disons que je me
suis arrêté en quinze mètres à peu près
par rapport à la la place où se trouve à
la période où enfin 15 mètres presque
gentil chez me 40,5 m on va aller tomber
ton 45 mètres d'eux était mort n'était
pas immédiatement
c'est proférées font preuve à la
préfecture
le serbe qui sait faire
l'an passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 1h30 et sur chaque ligne le dernier
train rejoint son terminus
quand on a fermé les grilles des 330
citation de la ratp
le métro change encore de visages
exotique le jour il devient alors un peu
fantastique aux quatre coins du réseau
est pauvre quatre heures seulement
s'ouvrent des chantiers souterrain à
hyères
tout autour sur des kilomètres de
couloirs vides sur l'été rendu au
silence mais où les lumières ne
s'éteignent pas quelques centaines
d'habitants clandestins cela s'organise
un refuge pour la nuit
[Musique]
les brigades de surveillance de la ratp
inspectent chaque nuit quelques stations
deux ou trois tunnels l'évacuation d'un
clochard mais pas seulement une
nécessité du règlement ce n'est pas
seulement une partie de cache cache un
peu absurde
c'est un rituel quotidien
[Musique]
mavuba
ah oui
j'ai pas cherché un paradoxe
enfin tu m'aimes brillante passe
cher archies %
[Musique]